the Joe Rogan experience when you look
at the future of Native American tribes
in the United States and again as you
said you know Native Americans that are
in these reservations are United States
citizens mm-hmm but it's it's such an
unusual situation that really we only
have a comparison to Canada with their
first nations mm-hmm
what what do you think happens in the
future when we go from 1900 you were
talking about the the the the past of
1900 to today it's a abysmal 120 years
other than the economic success of the
casinos what do you what do you
anticipate happening in the next hundred
years it's it's hard to tell I know a
lot of tribes have been diversifying
their economic development without our
culture's we won't survive in fact many
elders and you may have read it in Black
Elk speaks that that we're no longer who
we are without our culture without our
languages and likely will no longer be
recognized by the federal government
unless we are Indian enough you know so
those things are really important to who
we are in the next hundred years and I
think it's it's those things that we
will be rebuilding over the next hundred
years healing from the last and and
moving forward with a newfound
understanding of who we are and a
stronger identity and self what that
actually looks like and what's important
I think that we are so still so
dependent on the great white father and
what happens with the u.s. politics and
whether we have a voice there or not
we've got great organizations that help
advocate for Indian country in general
there's a National Congress of American
Indians which has been around for about
75 years and it helps lobby and educate
Congress
and keeps tribes informed about what's
going on in politics and advocate for
many of those interests there are groups
like ours that are advocating for more
cultural revitalization and
strengthening identity and protecting
our youth so I think part of what we're
we're we've been building is is really a
coalition of organizations and tribes to
strengthen who we are and kind of
correct the misfortunes of our history I
know we we still have tribal nations out
there that are living with egregious
poverty and and and issues that still
seem so far away from being corrected
but you know like my grandma always said
where there's hope where there's life
there's hope so I think we just continue
to I mean we've frickin survived for
this long and this coronavirus isn't
going to take us out either
I mean we're gonna continue to push
forward and and and try to have a better
future for our kids just like anybody
else just like anybody else and I think
that's that's what's important is that
we're not we're not on the stage with
everyone else we're not at the table
where decisions are being we're not in
the room where it happens that Native
Americans are not being treated with the
same respect as other people from other
countries so like the culture of Mexico
or the culture of Guatemala or hell
they're not in they're not being treated
well but we respect them as a culture
like they're they're thought of as I
mean we're not invading Mexico you know
I'm saying I mean whether whether you're
not you really what if border walls and
we're not looking at them as something
in feet we're looking at them as another
country mm-hmm we don't look at Native
Americans the same way we look
any week and maybe it's because you are
also United States citizens they don't
look at them the same way we have the
same like the respect for people that
live in a sovereign nation another
sovereign nation even though this is a
sovereign nation inside of our nation it
doesn't I think you would agree doesn't
get the same respect that other
sovereign nations right oh absolutely
[Applause]